Heavenly Father once more I just pray
for renewed strength and vigor
uh
as we meditate now upon and study the
subject of hermeneutics what did the
prophet mean by what the prophet said
father give us wisdom and understanding
now I pray in Jesus name amen
I want you to start out with me in the
book of second Timothy Chapter 2 and
verse 15. second Timothy 2
and verse 15 who would like to read that
for us second Timothy 2 and 15.
okay
I'm gonna have Kevin Reed here in just a
moment and then also
um
I'm gonna have a few of you read if you
have different translations Kevin you're
using the what again
Christian Standard Bible
um
second Timothy 2 15 go ahead and read it
okay
correctly teaching the word of Truth
foreign
dividing does somebody have something
different
rightly handling
accurately handling
well you gotta like that squeak don't
you
and you'll see here that the living
Bible says know what his word says and
means
what does it mean by rightly dividing
correctly teaching
rightly handling accurately handling
and before even the teaching part comes
you've got to understand what you're
dealing with
you've got to understand what it says if
you're going to teach somebody what it
says
know what his word says and what it
means I want you to read that quote
there from first elected messages page
44. this is interesting I think
Ellen White says here letters come to me
in treating an answer
I know that many men take the
testimonies the Lord has given and apply
them as they suppose they should be they
should be applied picking out a sentence
here and there taking it from its proper
what
connection and applying it according to
their idea
thus poor souls become bewildered
when could they read in order all that
has been given they would see the true
application and would not become
confused
much that purports to be a message from
Sister white serves the purpose of what
misrepresenting sister white making her
testify in favor of things that are not
in accordance with her mind and judgment
this makes her work very trying
reports fly from one to another
regarding what sister white has said
each time the report is repeated it
grows larger if Sister white has
anything to say leave her to say it
none is called upon to be a mouthpiece
for sister White
a prophet of the Prophet as it were
Ellen White had a problem with people
taking her writings believe it or not
and misapplying them and saying well
didn't you hear what sister white says
here and she would catch wind of it and
say that's not it all what I meant to
say
you're taking that way have you ever
been taken out of context
and somebody says well you said oh yeah
I said that but it was right after I
said this
you got me complete out completely out
of context you've had that happen before
well she had it imagine what a prophet
would have you don't have to imagine if
you've been in The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church for a while you've probably heard
these things before well that's what
we're looking at why hermeneutic some
people say hey why don't we just take
Illinois justice as it reads
well we're not saying we shouldn't take
it just as it reads but the problem is
some people don't read very well
and I don't mean
I don't mean in in their reading ability
but sometimes it's in the comprehension
and so we're going to look at some rules
uh incidentally hermeneutics it says
they're up at the top is derived from a
Greek word meaning to interpret that's
all it means to interpreting and I like
what Roger said in the heading up
there basically the key point in
hermeneutics is to understand what the
prophet meant by what the prophet said
we can read what she said do we get what
she meant
there's a story I'll share it now I
think I've got a reference to myself in
the notes I do
the story of Moishy the tailor I don't
know if you've heard the story you
probably will pick up on it as I tell
you a little bit about it
but in uh what was it 9 9th century Rome
uh The Story Goes I don't know that it's
a true story but it was illustrating the
point which you'll get in a moment
uh they decided uh the the Cardinals in
Rome decided they wanted to get rid of
the Jews the Pope says we can't just get
rid of the Jews and have them leave like
that we've got to have a reason we've
got to come up with some good scheme hey
I know
why don't we have them send a
representative
and they can come and they'll ask me and
we'll ask them three questions
and they have to answer every question
correctly or they'll be sent out
of Rome
good plan good plan let's go and so they
communicated the news to the Jews and
the Jews were panicked they're like oh
man what are we going to do we they're
gonna we need we need to send the rabbi
the rabbi can go and answer he says hold
on a minute I'm just a Rabbi this local
synagogue the pope he's ahead of the
world
okay well uh maybe a talmudic scholar we
could get a talmudic scholar I mean that
he would be able to meet the pope
detailment of scholar says wait a minute
I'm just a scholar of the talmud the the
pope he's the eminent he's the
preeminent scholar of the world
so as they're sitting here deliberating
one of the Jews who was a tailor his
name is Moshi he says
I'll go talk to him
I said you're going to go talk to him he
says hey I've been answering foolish
questions from Christians for years now
what's three more
and in the whole
anyway mushy ended up going he was the
one that ended up going before the pope
and as he got there
Pope was kind of surprised they'd send a
tailor in but uh Moshi got in and the
pope laid out the ground rules and he
says okay let's get started
when she's like let's cut to it let's go
ahead with the first question
so the pope held out a finger like this
why she responded he held out to
the pope said amazing
amazing
so the Pope says okay okay here comes
the next one
he held out his hands like this
and Moshi responded by going like this
and the Pope says I can't believe it
you've answered the first two questions
right but you've got to get all three
right if you guys are going to stay in
Rome
say reached in his robe when he pulls
out an apple
so moist moisture reaches in his satchel
and he pulls out a flat piece of matzo
matzo bread
and the Pope says I can't believe it you
have answered all three questions
correctly this is incredible your people
are allowed to stay
and so when she goes on his way and the
Cardinals who are in the other room they
come in and they say how could you allow
this to happen
we could have gotten rid of those
pestilential Jews
those pesky and he says uh
I couldn't help it he answered all the
questions right
I held out one finger meaning there's
only one God
but he responded by saying yes
but there's father and son who are one
he says so then
I held my hands out over my head in a
circle like this saying there's Unity
only in heaven but he responded by
saying yes but the kingdom of God is on
the Earth
he says then I pulled out an apple
representing that heretical theory that
the Earth is round
and he pulled out a flattened disc
proving that the Earth is flat
meanwhile back at the ranch
mushy goes back to the Jews and like
what happened hey he says calm down
we're staying we're we're staying you
beat the pope he says yeah you got to
know how to handle these Christians I
said well how'd you do it he says well
first thing he did is he pointed his
finger at me saying I'm going to poke
out your eye
he said So I responded by telling him
poke out both of yours
then he said
then he said he told then he told me
then he told me he says I'm going to
round up all you Jews and he said I told
him we're staying right here
then he said he pulled out his lunch so
I pulled out mine
[Laughter]
and of course the point of the little
Parable is two people can get a
different idea
from reading the same thing or being in
the same experience
and that's the purpose and the need for
hermeneutics it's kind of funny little
story isn't it
so we're going to look at some basic
rules
for interpretation we're staying right
here I like that part
basic rules of interpretation internal
and these are listed by the way in
Herbert Douglas's book but we're just
I've enumerated them here through this
handout number one recognize that the
Bible and the writings of Ellen White
are the product of thought inspiration
we've already talked about that quite a
bit there are certain things that if you
believe in a verbal inspiration you're
going to have problems that you're not
going to have if you understand the mode
of inspiration in the scripture it's
going to solve a lot of problems for you
in reading the Bible and in the spirit
of Prophecy we'll see that even as we go
on with some of the other things we look
at number two recognize the fact that
word definitions change over time
now you may read something
and say well this is exactly what it
says but for example Ellen White says
that working with human Minds is one of
the nicest works
that there is
what does that mean it's a nice work to
work with human mind if you look in the
dictionary you will find this definition
by nice letter a showing or requiring
great Precision or sensitive discernment
we don't use nice that way anymore as
much
uh when we talk about nice we just talk
about Pleasant
so word definitions can change
intercourse
today we all generally think of when we
hear intercourse we say oh we should be
talking about that
well we just have boiled down it used to
they used to say differentiate
intercourse and sexual intercourse but
most of us think sexual intercourse we
hear the word intercourse means
interaction the definition there
dealings are Communications between
persons or groups
but oftentimes today we may read that
word and get a whole different meaning
C gay
of course we don't use gay anymore like
they used to you know when somebody used
to say you know my he's a gay young man
you know you don't hear phrases like
that quite the same way anymore
you you pick up an old book you know and
the children were acting very gay you
know it was a word it was in use
you understand what I'm saying but today
and you see there the dictionary
definition showing or characterized by
cheerfulness or light-hearted excitement
Mary these are just examples uh here's
one that I didn't put down there I put
it in my notes
Sanitarium
Ellen White talks about sanitariums in
our work we think sanitarium man when
you and I think of a sanitarium what do
we think of
some Asylum right so you keep crazy
people but Sanitarium
or alternately sanatorium in the
dictionary reads this a health resort
okay so when you're reading online she
says we have sanitariums like man and
this is the stuff you find on websites
oh look at the Adventists have these
salmon they got all these lunatics in
their church and that's why they had to
have these Santa
give me a break find out what the word
meant when it was used you understand
that
okay so recognize the fact that word
definitions change over time
number three understand the use of
hyperbole
hyperbole the definition there is a
figure of speech in which exaggeration
is used for emphasis or effect as I can
sleep for a year
or this book weighs a ton now if I told
you man this book weighs a ton would you
think it weighs a literal time no but
the critics do that with elements
writings on the websites ah Ella might
said this it understand expressions and
the use of hyperbole one of the things
she uses one phrase she'll say not one
in 20 are prepared to end the Earthly
existence uh statements like that well
she didn't really sit down I I I very
well I know better that the Lord didn't
show her and say exactly one in 20 of
our people less and so it's a figure of
speech it means very few are prepared
you follow that but there are people
that take things you know they'll take a
a statement of hyperbole very literally
and you can imagine how that distorts
the meaning of the expression are you
with me so far
number four
understand the meaning of a phrase
first example there phrenology
psychology and mesmerism look at the
statement from messages to Young People
page 57 The Sciences of phrenology
psychology and mesmerism have been the
channel through which Satan has come
more directly to this generation and
wrought with that power which has to
characterize his work near the close of
probation
okay wow says Satan's working through
psychology he says that's the science
he's working through
but then if you go to messages I'm sorry
mind character and personality page 10
volume 1 page 10 says the true
principles of what
psychology are found in the Holy
scriptures
uh when you read we're going to see this
in the next point
uh phrenology psychology and mesmerism
were referred to as the Sciences of the
mind they were kind of lumped together
in Ellen White's day
and she had no issue with
a psychology that followed true
principles
but she did take issue with the
psychology that was was the type that
would go with the phrenology remember I
talked about phrenology the other day
what's phrenology again
setting the bumps on the head and
mesmerism hypnotism
things like that
so you've got to understand the use of
the phrase is she condemning the whole
thing or is is is the uh is she
basically using a phrase to talk about
you know people in her day would use
that phrase science is psychology uh
phrenology and mesmerism
she's just talking about the Sciences of
the Mind as employed in her day okay do
you follow that follow what I'm saying
and
uh so it's not somebody could take that
one statement and come to you and say
man psychology is the devil
and some of it is
but the point is here she's not
categorially condemning psychology all
the way across the board do you
understand that but you see how somebody
could take that
just like the PO the pope and Moishy
with their different somebody could take
that and come up with a completely
different idea than what she was trying
to get across okay you're with me on
that
number five
recognize the possibility of an of
imprecise expressions in other words the
Expressions weren't meant to convey this
very precisely
um well we're looking at the same a very
similar statement
um
notice the letter A a general statement
May utilize commonly used terms and
expressions of which usage has changed
over the course of time you have to
remember the time that Ellen White wrote
these things some of the usages have
changed now I'm not telling you to make
of none affect the testimonies and say
they're not relevant and we'll see that
more as we flesh out some of these
things but I am saying you have to
recognize that certain things have
changed even in her day in 1861 notice
what she wrote phrenology and mesmerism
are very much exalted
they are good in their place
pardon me
let's see
oh there's a bump there and there I
think you're crazy man
it's good in its place
but they are seized upon by Satan as his
most powerful ages mesmerism hypnotism
is good in its place
was she actually saying mesmerism and
phrenology were good
but they're seized upon by Satan as
these most powerful agents to deceive
and Destroy Souls Satan uses these very
things to destroy virtue and lay the
foundation of spiritualism now in 1884
you see the very same statement but she
has changed part of it
why because she didn't want to be
misunderstood evidently she already had
been notice how she says it the Sciences
which treat of the human mind are very
much exalted they are good in their
place but they are seized upon by Satan
as his powerful agents to deceive and
Destroy souls in her data phrenology and
mesmerism these were the Sciences of the
mind in general
they didn't mean that every the reading
the bumps and all these things in and of
themselves and she wasn't saying these
are these are really good things we need
to have this done
she was talking about the Sciences of
the mind but his people said oh wow
sister white says we're going to be gone
to the mesmerist or the phrenologist she
said uh pardon me the Sciences which
treat the human mind are good in their
place
and of course she wrote statements like
what we saw in messages to young people
there and some others and and try to
clarify it a little bit do you kind of
follow that
Expressions that are made may not be
precise she she may have made a
statement and not
you know and I can imagine remember the
prophets putting these things in their
own words you can't always imagine how
somebody's going to take what you say
have you ever been taken wrong in
something you wrote
you do your best to try to convey what
you mean and your meaning is correct but
somebody says well you put this yeah but
that's not what that that's not how I
managed to to say and you read it back
to him
you know the wording is there it me but
it means two different things to do two
different people as Ellen White
expressed things again this idea of
verbal inspiration would say well God
dictated it just this way no she tried
to put it in her own words to best
convey the thought
and somebody would get that thought and
say well no I don't I don't go for this
or would would take some extreme
position on it she in this case in 1884
rephrased it to try to eliminate the
confusion
and again a verbal inspirationist they'd
have a real hard time with that because
she changed the wording from what God
told her you know there's a
contradiction but a thought inspiration
uh someone we understand thought
inspiration we understand why uh the
prophet may change the wording of
something you with me on that
number six
never I'm sorry number six look
carefully at the immediate context of
something
Christ object lessons page 155 have you
ever read this passage that says that we
are never to say or feel that we are
saved
have you read that says it right there
in Christ object lessons page 155 says
we are never to say or feel that we are
saying
there have been seven-day Adventists to
this day
are you I'm
I hope I am
what John says in first John 5 11 and 12
he who has the son has life I write
these things to you so that you may know
that you have eternal life well I think
I do I hope I do I sure hope
Ellen White says we aren't supposed to
say that we're saved
but if you look at the statement in its
context what does she say she's talking
about Peter who was so overconfident
that when Christ said Peter you're going
to fall Peter says no I'm not
man you don't know me Lord like I know
myself I'm saved she's addressing more
of the one saved always saved mentality
that was going around a person who
believes it but now I'm saved I can't be
lost she says be careful of that we
shouldn't be taught to think or feel
that we are saved saved in such a sense
that we can never be lost you follow
that she wasn't saying we can't have
confidence that we have salvation in
Christ now
you follow that
are you guys with me on that
but if you take that out of context it
can distort the whole picture
uh Jesus never laughed
she says in manuscript releases 18.
and so we uh
listen now you shouldn't laugh
you know and then people you know and
here's what happens too
inevitably you have the sanctimonious
Saint who doesn't laugh
you all just laughed at that Moishy
thing
you know Council says we shouldn't laugh
and people will take that position and
now
I thought you guys were I thought you
guys were solid Seventh-Day Adventists
you all just laughed I'm going to go to
a school where people are believe in the
spirit of Prophecy see you've got people
that that's what happens you get these
attitudes read the statement in context
and you'll see that the issue she was
addressing a woman about uh going to
these parties where it was hilarity and
Glee and forgetful of spiritual things
and that was the context that she wrote
in
take the immediate context don't look at
it the same thing we do with the
scripture brothers and sisters you got
to take it in its immediate context or
you're going to come up with a wrong
conclusion something she never intended
to say
you follow that
we clear on that next one
recognized that context can change the
meaning of a word
uh we just talked about it in being
saved what did she mean by that she says
we shouldn't have confidence in
Salvation no she's talking about the one
saved always saved idea and you read it
and when you read the context you see
what she meant by saved there look at
these two statements Christ came forth
from the tomb glorified she says in
Desire of Ages on page 780. he craved
forth from the tomb glorified and yet
25 Pages later on Desire of Ages 805 she
says Christ had not yet been glorified
oh This Woman's confused
unless you look at it in the context
what she's talking about glorified as he
came from forth from the tomb with the
glorified body he'd been resurrected
but he'd not yet ascended to his father
he'd not yet received the the the the
role that he was going to have as he
entered into heaven and the procession
of his inauguration you follow that
she doesn't contradict she's not
contradicting yourself but the context
Bears a different meaning just like that
word saved when you read it in the
context uh addresses more than once
saved always saved idea versus
having confidence in yourself of your
salvation in Christ are you do you
follow me
you have any questions
all right
next one number eight recognize the
challenge of semantics
different words mean different things to
different people
okay
um
moishi is one good example of that and
that's where I had that story look at
what Ellen White says here and uh
selected messages volume 3 page 79 and
80. there are many who interpret that
which are right in the light of their
own preconceived opinions you know what
this means a division in understanding
and diverse opinions is the sure result
how to write in a way to be understood
by those to whom I address important
matter is a problem I cannot solve
I'm trying my best she says to make
myself understood but how to convey
myself so that people understand what
I'm saying is a problem I can't I can't
solve but I will endeavor to write much
less
so she says I'm getting taken wrong so
many times because people are
interpreting according to their own will
and their own opinions she says I'll
Endeavor to write much less owing to the
influence of Mind upon mind those who
misunderstand can lead others to
misunderstand by the interpretation they
Place upon the subjects from my pen
one understands them as he thinks they
should be in accordance with his ideas
another puts his construction upon the
Matter written and confusion is the sure
result she says I'm just going to write
less from now on
next one
this is an interesting statement it
seems impossible for me to be understood
by those who have had the light but what
have not walked in it just what we're
saying earlier truth is truth to those
who practice it you haven't walked in
the light you're gonna have a hard time
really grasping what it is what my what
I might say in private conversations
would be so repeated as to make it mean
exactly the opposite to what it would
have meant had the hearers been
Sanctified in Mind and Spirit
I'm afraid to speak even to my friends
for afterwards I hear sister white said
this her sister white said that my words
are so rested and misinterpreted that
I'm coming to the conclusion that the
Lord desires me to keep out of large
assemblies and refuse private interviews
what I say is reported in such a
perverted light that it is straight new
and strange to me
have you seen this
it is mixed with words spoken by men to
sustain their own theories
understand that different things mean
different things to different people
there's the challenge of semantics but
you know what
God's word you know we've got to we've
gotta
we've got to not seek to interpret these
things according to how we already view
things
and we're going to talk about that as we
get into this next section uh the
external principles
uh rules but rather of interpretation
this first one is is majorly important
include all that the prophet has said on
the subject Matthew 20 or I'm sorry Luke
24 there is when Jesus told those
disciples on the road to Emmaus fools
and slow of heart to believe what
all that the prophets have spoken
you need to be more familiar with what
the prophets have spoken people will
pick up one thing but not get the whole
spectrum of what Ellen White has written
on a subject
um
you know Isaiah 28 13 I note there line
upon line precept upon precept the Bible
says here a little and there a little
you want to take you want to get the
whole picture you know a lot of times
and this is an example on the nature of
Christ I'm just going to bring it up
here I've got it on my computer
when we talk about the nature of Christ
a lot of times a person wants to sustain
their position so they'll read the
things that agree with their position
and not read all of what the prophet has
spoken
I'm just going to throw a couple things
at you here
this is from the book confrontation
page 17 it says the work of redemption
could be carried out only by the
Redeemer taking the place of Fallen Adam
with the sins of the world laid upon Him
etc etc I'm not going to read you the
whole passages here uh from page 18 of
the same book these are all just from
the book confrontation by the way
what love what amazing condescension the
king of glory proposed to Humble himself
to fall in humanity
he would place his feet in Adam's steps
he would take man's Fallen nature
page number 32
says in behalf of the race with a
weakness of Fallen man upon him
he was to stand The Temptations of Satan
upon all points on which man could be
assailed
and page 32 in order to elevate Fallen
man Christ must reach him where he was
he took human nature and bore the
infirmities and degeneracy of the race
he who knew no sin became sin for us in
taking Humanity that's the way she
applies that okay
you follow those now listen to these
steps to Christ page 93 he is a brother
in our infirmities in all points tempted
like as we are but as the sinless one
his nature recoiled from evil
hmm
and listen to this next one Bible
commentary volume 5 page 11 28. be
careful exceedingly careful as to how
you dwell upon the human nature of
Christ do not set him before the people
as a man with the propensities to sin he
is the second Adam she goes on to say
the Incarnation of Christ has ever been
and ever will remain a mystery we talked
about that the other day
that which has revealed is for us and
for our children but let every human
being be warned from the ground of
making Christ all together human such A1
as ourselves for it cannot be
the exact time well it goes on
now I don't have a problem personally
saying that Christ took a fallen nature
Ellen White says he took a fallen nature
the question is what did she mean by
Fallen nature she clearly means it
wasn't still wasn't exactly like my
nature you just got that
he couldn't have been like my nature the
carnal mind is enmity against the law of
God it cannot be subject to the law of
God it isn't subject neither indeed can
be he couldn't have had that okay and so
the point is and I'm not going to go
into all the details there but I've said
you know for us to sometimes we we get
on the sides of these things and debate
them she says it's going to be a mystery
through Eternal ages right there
but a lot of times you've got a person
who gather up their statements over here
and then a person gathers up their
statements over here take all of the
Prophet is spoken and I'll tell you what
if you take all that the prophet has
spoken there's a lot more on that
subject the more you read the more
silent you're going to be and trying to
be a real dogmatic about it I'll tell
you that right now
a person who comes to me and takes a
real dogmatic position I'll be honest
with you I've to me they've just told me
that they haven't really done a lot of
research into all that the prophet has
spoken you know don't be real dogmatic
about something that we're told is going
to be a mystery take all that the
prophet has spoken and that's the same
with any subject the more you read on
subjects you will start to understand
the broad picture
let's look at some other things here an
isolated statement may lead to very
wrong conclusions look at second
testimonies page 399 here oh let's back
up I didn't read that statement from
first select a message is 42. Ellen
White says here the testimonies
themselves will be the key that will
explain the message given as scripture
is explained by scripture
that just means compare what I've
written don't narrow yourself down in
one area read all the prophet is spoken
the next statement an idol an isolated
statement may lead to very wrong
conclusions second testimonies 399 eggs
should not be placed upon your table
well there it is you hear what the
prophet says don't every eggs it says
right there
now you know what happened
a Dr Chris
read those statements and Dr Kress
determined
that he was not going not going to eat
eggs he was not going to place him on
his table went off as a missionary went
to a place where he could not get any
vitamin B12 in what he was eating now
you and I have a lot of advantages diet
wise today I mean we can go down and buy
soy milk at the grocery store with B12
in it but they couldn't do those things
and so he laid off all animal products
he wasn't using eggs and the man his
health was failing him he was weak and
sickly and pale and Ellen White was
shown this man in vision and she said
you're trying to forward a work in
another place you're talking about
health reform and people are looking at
you and saying who's this sick guy
telling me about health
and she wrote to him and said right
there in this passage
um look at number four
again it's misnumbered
she says put into your diet something
you have left out it is your duty to do
this get eggs of healthy fowls use these
eggs cooked or raw Do Not For a Moment
suppose that it will not be right to do
this
and Dr Crest did what Ellen White said
and put those eggs into his diet
and did that for the rest of his life
his health restored to him and he kept
up with that practice he was suffering
from pernicious anemia lack of B12 could
have been very serious
and praise the Lord that he gave the
counsel in the time that he did what
happened
Dr Crest read an isolated statement he
didn't get the whole picture okay
you follow what I'm saying now I'll be
honest with you I don't eat eggs I don't
eat dairy products especially today
because the disease in the animal
kingdom but there are occasions when
I've had them there are occasions you
know there are people that when they get
into this mindset you know Pastor
Richard o'fill says you know said
something once that I I thought was
interesting he said to me you know he
says every once in a while he says
every once in a while I have a chocolate
chip cookie just so I don't feel like
I'm better than everybody else
people tend sometimes
people tend sometimes when they're
following certain practices to look at
everybody else who isn't following them
and say
you know brother one of these days when
you're converted
you're not going to eat eggs anymore
in this setting in Dr cress's setting it
was something that he should not that he
needed to do yet there was another
setting this testimonies too the issue
there was that they were the children
the young boys had Str had had had
um there's problems with self-abuse in
the family strong uh sexual urges and
problems
and eggs are one thing that very much
uh enhances that
and in that household Ellen White said
you're better off not putting those on
your table but it wasn't a blanket
statement for everybody do you
understand
are you following that you've got to
read all that the prophet has spoken and
take in what's being said
before you decide I'm gonna you know as
a rule Ellen White told us to to uh lead
away from animal products why do you
know why
you know this is the time this is the
this whole thing here is where we really
I really want to spend some time but
we'll be in it in the morning uh disease
um that's that's it I I did when I did
Bible work in Alabama I had a woman
brand new to the Adventist Church
she had just come in I was Bible
studying with her she'd come in through
an Evangelistic series
um and in Alabama she went to a church
another a neighboring church with a
friend of hers there was a health
lecturer there Seventh-day Adventist and
the guy told him
he got to talking about eggs and he said
why would you want to eat an egg anyway
it's nothing but a chicken's period
boy how's that for a winning
presentation of help
I love it now let me tell you something
this morning
listen to this
listen carefully
don't ever listen you're going to get
yourself in hot water don't ever use a
reason
for why you do something that God never
gave us
if he was right then how could Ellen
White ever tell anybody you know if it's
filthy and this that you know how can
anyone ever say you need to be eating
eggs
do you understand that people give a lot
of reasons for why we shouldn't eat meat
why should you know the main reason
element said to get away from these
things there's a few the main reason is
disease in the animal kingdom that's the
main reason and when you understand the
main reason it makes a lot more sense
than manufacturing reasons
to give some Shock value to somebody
well if I tell them this it'll get them
off eggs you have to get right back on
them because they have no clear
principle to work from do you understand
that question isn't the real reason no
behind that that since our body's
supposed to be the temple of God
is a Living Sacrifice that we're to take
the best substances
so that it can afford US clear
discernment absolutely I mean that's a
real issue because also said that
because of all the sugar people are
eating it'd be better for them to eat
obviously there are other principles
involved in health reform but I just
want you to understand that that uh
you know some people will put all
objectionable or questionable items of
diet on the same level and they're not
they're not
um
sugar Ellen might count it against sugar
but you also said it you know it's not a
it's not an issue to eat some sugar
so you know getting understanding what
was what was being conveyed what the
point she was trying to get across makes
a big difference Dr Kress missed this
and the guy would listen if he hadn't
had that testimony the guy would have
suffered some serious problems with a
B12 deficiency
and so uh you've got to read all that
the prophet has spoken on a subject
number two every statement must be
understood within its historical context
okay uh letter A regarding the
testimonies nothing is ignored nothing
is ignored nothing is cast aside but
what
time and place must be considered this
is Ellen White's pen you've got to
consider time and place situations
change the situation here from these two
statements uh we'll go to number two
first when the Judgment of the General
Conference which is the highest
Authority that God has upon the Earth is
exercised private Independence and
private judgment must not be maintained
but surrendered
she penned that in 1875. and in 19 1896
there were people maintaining the
general conference says and you need to
follow it
only the general conference is going
down a pathway in 1896 that needed to be
corrected and they said sister white
says it haven't you read it don't you
believe in the spirit of Prophecy this
is the highest voice the highest
Authority on the earth the general
conference and she counseled in 1896
found in Last Day Events page 50 The
Voice from Battle Creek which has been
regarded as Authority and counseling how
the work should be done is no longer the
voice of God
the situation has changed
and it was after that
where they reorganized in 1901 that
Ellen White once again said the general
conference is the voice of God in the
earth okay because they had come back in
line do you follow that
but there are times
that's questionable
something up here
but there are times
that the the time changes certain
certain situations for example the
number one there Israel's failure at
kadish barnia
they went in God said take the land they
said we can't take the land the Giants
in the land Caleb and Joshua said but
it's God's battle they said we're going
to Stone you to death and God steps in
and says okay because of your Rebellion
you're going 40 years in the wilderness
then what'd they do
okay now we'll go now we'll go take the
land right
what happened was God with him no time
had changed situation changed God's
counsel before to go in and take the
land had changed because of their
reaction because of what they had done
you follow that
so time a historical context can change
the way something uh the way that the
council is to be understood and place
she says time and place must be
understood or considered
uh example letters to the churches in
Revelation 2.
and three
imagine
you know there were different situations
in all those letters weren't they
in in the letter to the Church of uh in
Sardis and letter uh to the laodicean
church and Philadelphia Church in
thyatira they're all different issues
right imagine that the messenger got
those letters mixed up and set the wrong
one to the wrong churches
well what would have happened
would the testimony have the desired
effect
no
and look at this uh the diagram there
below let's imagine
in the first picture there church a
is sent a five mile testimony you've got
a goal okay and that goal is a balanced
view of the truth Church a has some
issues and so a strong testimony is sent
to church a to get them back on the mark
at the same time Church B is closer to
the goal but they're not there yet so
the testimony isn't quite so direct
deals with some different issues but
in the picture below if the testimonies
were switched what would happen
as Church a gets the wrong testimony the
one that was supposed to go to B well
they get closer to the goal but they're
still not there
they still got three miles to go but
they're a little better off but then
church B now his clear sword clear over
to the other side of the issue they've
overdone it
so that when a testimony is given in a
certain place
if you apply it to the wrong place it
may have the wrong effect you follow
that look at the statement there below
in the review of March 17 1868 James
White commented on this difficulty
saying quote
she speaking of his wife works to this
disadvantage namely she makes strong
appeals to the people which a few feel
deeply and take strong positions and go
to extremes you know a lot of times
you've got a dead Church
you're preaching to the church you're
trying to wake him up you've got a few
conscientious people they're just like
oh we need to repent you know and the
rest of they're not the ones you're
preaching to they're already there
they're on fire you're saying you guys
need to dedicate more time to the
service of the lord they're already
there all the time they're like pastor
says we need to dedicate more time and
because they're conscientious they want
to dedicate even more time
while the rest of the folks are sitting
there and saying yeah whatever
and they go off and go their way and
this is what James White is saying
she she makes strong appeals to the
people which a few feel deeply and then
take strong positions and go to extremes
then to save the cause from ruin and
consequence of these extremes she's
obliged to come out with reproofs for
extremists in a public manner
this is better than to have things go to
Pieces but the influence of both the
extremes and the reproofs are terrible
on the cause and brings upon Mrs White a
threefold burden here's the difficulty
what she may say to urge the tardy the
Five Mile church is taken by the prompt
to urge this the two-mile Church to urge
them over the mark
and what she may say to caution the
prompt
zealous in cautious ones is taken by the
tardy as an excuse to remain too far
behind
you kind of get the picture there
some people need straighter testimonies
than others some places need straighter
counsel than others and you and I have
to understand the condition that existed
and the place that that testimony was
given both in the scripture and in the
spirit of Prophecy so that you don't
overstep the mark do you follow that
does that make sense
question
about how to find that out in her
writings and also to go back to like
like if you're reading something in
Ellen White and you come across
something that you suspect is an
expression from your time how can you
work that up
let me say this on that this is not an
issue where and I remember when I became
a vegetarian and people were like are
you counting out how much protein you're
getting
are you are you figuring you've got you
know you've got to mix your proteins
have you counted your your different
amino acids
give me a break
you know just to eat a well-balanced
diet okay and in Ellen White don't sit
there in every question you're like okay
where'd this come from but the the
problem where this comes where this
becomes a problem is when a person takes
an isolated statement or even an
isolated testimony but they're not
reading what Ellen White says on the
subject in general
what I would recommend to you is that
you read what she says on the subject in
general now let me make a recommendation
this morning I'll make the you to you
the recommendation that g Edward Reed
made in a tape that I heard at one time
and I thought it was good and I'll just
make the recommendation to you if
You Don't Own
a copy of the Ellen White CD-ROM and you
have a computer that you can use it on
go sell something insignificant like
your bed and buy one
I thought that was good I'm going to
tell you something God gives a last day
profit what is more important for you
and I to have with the council that
profit You've Got A CD-ROM with you can
search everything she wrote on something
now you can get on the internet for
those who don't have it but I'm going to
tell you something I regularly search
that CD-ROM if I have a subject that I
want to know more about I'll type in and
I'll go through and I'll read because
it's easy to find everything on the same
subject and you can get a good overview
a good balanced view of what she's
saying you don't get one isolated
statement you say oh wait a minute this
one here and then you get a few more and
it's like oh it fleshes it out a little
bit you say I see what she was saying
and you get the general point of what's
being said you follow that
and so I wouldn't worry about everything
you read and say I wonder if I should
apply this
as a general rule you're not going to
have that problem it's when you pick and
choose little parts that you start to
get into trouble
okay and we're going to talk about some
of those little Parts as we go on you
know some of those little issues diet is
one of them dress is one of them some of
these things that trip us up because we
need we we we get a we get a a narrow
viewpoint
what time are we done
we go to one we get 10 minutes
circumstances
look at the statement from third
selected messages page 217
LMI says here when I heard what the
objections were that children could not
let me give you the background
they're in a board meeting they were
talking about having a kindergarten
the board was opposed to it we can't
have a kindergarten why because sister
white says children should not be put
into school until eight to ten years of
age she was there on the board
so she responds to this and she says
when I heard what the objections were
that children could not go to school
until they were 10 years old I wanted to
tell you that there was not a Sabbath
keeping school when the light was given
to me
my mind has been greatly stirred in
regard to this idea my sister white has
said so and so and sister white has said
so and so and therefore we're going
right up to it
God wants us all to have common sense
and he wants us to reason from Common
Sense circumstances alter conditions
circumstances change the relation of
things
she says when I first gave it was given
the Council on eight to ten years old
the kids should enter school we didn't
have Adventist schools
and so she said I recommended that they
stay at home but here's what began to
happen
there began to be problems in Battle
Creek where you had this Adventist
ghetto you know what an Adventist ghetto
is don't you that's a little
sub-community of Adventists that just
think oh you know and you've got this
subculture and in Battle Creek here's
you had all these Adventists gathering
together huh
you had all these subcultures gathering
together and here's what happened
these these these uh Sabbath keeping
moms weren't sending their kids to
school until eight to ten and so what
they do they ran Wild
around the Battle Creek sanitarium and
the hospital there and as the and as and
she said we've got these kids running
around and the word she uses
um
let me get it for you you're going to
like this
she uses the phrase uh they go around
all link side you know like a cat like a
lynx
these talking about these kids
let me let me see if I can get it real
quick
yeah
okay no that's not it
just a second
here's a sanitarium this is from third
selective messages page 217. here's a
sanitarium and that sanitarium must
carry the highest possible influence
inside and out then if they see children
who come there sharp eye link side
wondering about with nothing to do
getting into mischief and all these
things it is painful to the senses of
those that want to keep the reputation
of the school therefore I from the light
God has given me declare that if there
is a family that has not the
capabilities of educating nor
disciplining and government over their
children requiring obedience the very
best thing for them to do is put them in
a place where they will obey
put them in a place where they'll be
required to obey because obedience is
better than sacrifice
they're letting their kids run wild see
that's not the point of the council I
didn't tell you keep the kids out of
school so you let them go run around
like wild banshees
you know but people would take these
isolated statements and so this is what
element made the point of she says my
mind has been stirred in this people say
well sister white said so we're going to
do it you know go check out everything
that I've said she's saying essentially
you've got to understand circumstances
circumstances alter things yes sir and
the worst part about it is back then
somehow excuse them because they don't
have the opportunity to get their hands
on everything she said that's right
whereas today we do and yet it still
happens yeah oh yeah it happens all the
time now but boy I tell you I'm going to
preach a sermon like that one time put
your kids where they're going to be
required to obey because you guys don't
discipline your kids whoo that'll go
over real well like a lead balloon
it's true we we and and that that's the
next part that uh I'm going to touch on
here we're going to pick up on it
tomorrow know the difference between
policy and principle
a policy
letter A an unerring I'm sorry a policy
is letter B we'll look at policy first
the application of some Eternal
principle to a particular situation
a rule okay a commandment
principle an unerring unchanging rule of
human conduct or behavior I'll put it
this way
up there's always a principle behind the
policy the policy is the rule the
principle is what's behind the rule the
reason behind the rule okay
for example
I don't know if they have these anymore
I've talked about this before the no
shirt no shoes no service you've heard
me talk about this before haven't you
the uh the signs you haven't they still
have those on these stores no shirt no
okay why what now that's the rule that's
the policy of the store no shirt no
shoes no service why do you think they
have that what do you think the reason
is behind that rule
okay sanitary reasons maybe health
reasons
Plus you know I mean some people are
just fat and it'd be disgusting
[Laughter]
boom
that's right
Hey look
um
what are other reasons
what are other reasons hey is that about
could that be a reason
yeah yeah it would be in my store I'm
with you brother okay what else Common
Sense people don't wear clothes okay
okay so you see there could be different
reasons to me you know maybe maybe uh
they've had an experience where the
people would come in with no shirt no
shoes tend to be bad customers I don't
know
you know
but the thing is
the thing is there's a policy behind uh
there's a principle behind the policy
okay there's a reason behind the rule
now when I lived in Ohio when I turned
18 years old
this is my pre-conversion days
and uh
you couldn't you couldn't uh in Ohio you
couldn't play pool until you're 18. you
go to the bowling alley you couldn't
play pool you could go bowling but you
couldn't play pool
so you're here in the bowling alley and
they're playing pool right there at the
pool tables but I can't go over there
unless I'm 18 years old
you know and so I went up one day and I
was talking to the lady and I said hey
what's the deal 18 years old to shoot
pool what's the deal with that she's
like oh you know she says there's a
bunch of rules on the on the on the rule
books that she says there's still a rule
on the rule books that says you've got
to have a horse watering trough every
block
so they don't enforce it
there's still a rule that there's a
horse watering trough for every block
now let me make this point
policies change
principles don't
okay now sometimes policies are outdated
but you're never safe
if you've got a good principle
you're never safe to take a policy
that's outdated and throw the whole
thing away
what you need to do is understand the
principle and reapply it
let's take for example a watering trough
every block why do you suppose they made
that rule
horses get tired and thirsty right
now
taking that principle let's reapply it
and if you reapplied it what would you
have on every block now
a gas station you follow that
so you want to understand the difference
between policies and principles
policies will change but principles will
not and you need to understand how to
take a principle and reapply a principle
we'll look at the first one here let's
all we have time for at this point
uh the bicycle craze how many of you
have heard about the well let's look at
it there the two statements Council uh
Christian Temperance 367 the exhibitions
in the bicycle craze are an offense to
God his wrath is kindled against those
who do such things
and look at number two there instead of
investing 100 in a bicycle
you would consider the matter well lest
it might be at the price of souls for
whom Christ died and for whom he has
made you responsible now I had somebody
ask me I've had people ask me for you on
a bicycle yes I do did you pay a hundred
dollars for it yeah she paid 130 dollars
for it
now well you know then you're apostate
you don't believe in the spirit of
Prophecy
question
what was she writing about does anybody
know anybody study this out what was she
writing about how many years wages on a
bike instead of okay a hundred dollars
then was not a hundred dollars now
this was two months salary and there
were people Seventh-Day Adventists yeah
the Lord's coming who were spending two
months salary to buy a bicycle while
their families didn't have food to eat
and sister white says you're getting
caught up in this bicycle fad
just to keep up with the Joneses she
says and that's why she says you'd be
better to consider the matter well it
might be the price for souls for whom
Christ died
you know you have some responsibilities
it was a very unreasonable expense
so people today they'll take that
bicycle thing
without
taking the full getting the full picture
and uh and then we get into all kinds of
trouble a question
if you were to take the principle and
reapply it today
how might it be reapplied
okay
if he says diamond rings could be could
be a number of things
I'm what's that
a Hummer yeah and even uh you know
nobody's gonna mention the car you drive
nobody's going to mention your own car
probably but we ought to think about
that huh usually it's like the car we
don't have
well
so I'm not going to say anything other
than to just say that's the point you
know it doesn't have to be limited to
Transportation but the point is
don't spend beyond your means especially
in a day when the Lord's cause needs
money to finish this work you follow
that no it's a good principle isn't it
but you've got to understand it before
you make policy out of it or try to hold
an old policy when the times have
changed
I really don't believe sister white
would condemn the writing of a bicycle
today in fact
if she would we've got to dismantle the
work overseas because our Minister's
over there using bicycles
because they can't afford cars
we're going to shut down the work in
Africa because the ministers over there
ride bicycles everywhere you know yeah
pictures of Kellogg on the bicycle you
know I I that's a good question I
haven't looked into that I don't know
how long it took for bicycle prices to
start to come down and I imagine that
they did quite a bit after the initial
craze
I think I I think that was more than
likely the case as bicycles got more
popular and more obviously increased
production in the in the cost came down
I want to look at this next one and then
we'll break
and that is uh
I just like this one education page 216
and 217 says if girls could learn to
harness and drive a horse
how many of you ladies know how to
amen
what's the matter with the rest of you
don't believe in spirit of Prophecy
you understand the point here if girls
could okay if girls could learn to
harness and drive a horse and to use the
saw and Hammer as well as to the rake in
the hoe that would be better fitted to
meet the emergencies of Life what's the
principle
what's the principle
Being Fit for emergencies
okay be prepared for the emergencies of
life so if we were to reapply it what
might a young lady learn how to do
change a tire on a car change the oil in
her car you know do some minor repairs
and things so
what else was that
found job and yeah you guys see you guys
see uh
Kevin and he'll tell you how to work on
your car he's going to class we can all
right well let's finish up we'll wrap up
with uh with a word of prayer let me ask
before I do that
uh has this has this has class today
been positive have you picked up some
things uh is this making sense what
we're talking about with the
hermeneutics I I really don't want us
you know I'm not trying to people get up
oh well wait a minute you're trying to
undo what the council says no I'm trying
to get us to understand what the council
says
I I and I'm going to tell you a little
bit tomorrow I'll share with you some of
my own experience with Spirit of
Prophecy I believe in the authority of
the Prophet I Believe In following what
the prophet says and it has been an
enrichment to my life but I'll tell you
what especially in Ministry those of you
who get involved especially in pastoral
Ministry
brother
I don't know how many of you are looking
into that you're going to run into a lot
of issues along this where you've got I
mean you just run into crazy business
that you and and and suddenly you know
where you thought you believed in the
spirit of Prophecy you thought you were
a faithful Minister you've got your
member coming up and saying well you
know I thought it you know in calling
you apostate because you have a bicycle
or whatever else and so it's important
to understand
what the prophet meant by what the
prophet said we're going to look at some
of the effect of what happens when
people take these things to extremes and
it never helps the cause
some people think they're they're
they're uh holding up the cause it never
helps the cause to take an extreme
position
like a chicken's period and all these
funny things here that doesn't help your
cause at all you're not going to win
anybody to message with that you follow
that
let's bow our heads forward a closing
prayer
Heavenly Father we do thank you and
praise you today for the gift of
Prophecy you've given
and father I pray that you help us to
understand that we have got to take all
that the prophet has spoken the prophet
herself has said that time and place
must be considered the prophet herself
has said that circumstances alter the
condition of things and that Common
Sense must be employed and father if we
believe the prophet we need to heed all
that the prophet has spoken I pray this
this afternoon that as these students go
out and try to reach out to those who
have been coming to the meetings father
I pray your spirit would go before them
prepare the hearts before them enable
them Lord to do what you've called them
to do and work in spite of them today in
spite of our weaknesses may your
strength be made perfect in weakness
May the uh
Spirit be with Scott tonight as he
preaches the message Lord and be with
each one of us that our hearts may be
stirred once again we ask and pray these
things in the name of Jesus and for his
sake amen